hello everyone and welcome back to our
mini dupe of saga we are continuing with
a really crazy game from the european
team championship 2019 from matumi
georgia uh it's a game from round one
and he faces
a very young and very talented the
danish grandmaster jonas bubia
and i think he just got his grandmaster
norm right before this tournament he's
actually the youngest dane ever
to to win the title of grand master so
it's quite an achievement in itself
but here he faces duba dubo has the
black pieces
so let's see let's see what happens here
uh yeah with the white pieces opens with
uh
not d4 he opens with e4 and it's uh it's
uh
pretty normal stuff until you know until
it uh
until it's not e5 knight f3 knights to
c6
and jonas goes for bishop to b5 the real
lopez is on the board we have a6
morphy's defense
bishop to a4 and now knight to f6 so
just nicely continuing the game with
castles and now bishop to e7
if there are some newer players who are
wondering why not to just capture the
pawn you can capture the pawn this is
perfectly fine but it's just a different
variation then you have to know what
happens after d4
or rook to e1 and so on and if you
prefer to
play it like this it's it's perfectly
fine uh but
uh dubo prefers the bishop to e7
variation for this game
uh obviously he he had it specially
prepared for for our young grandmaster
friend here
rook to e1 now developing the rook and
b5
pushing that bishop back bishop to b3
and here dub of castles
and now a4 so this is all very standard
when you have this
these pawns on a6 and b5 you will try
and undermine them with
a4 now just try you you will succeed and
here uh the moves that are always played
here are bishop to b7
uh and b4 uh so there are some other
moves but these are the the absolute top
main moves but for this game
uh duboff prepared d5 and a d5 it it
kind of looks too good to be
true like uh if you can push uh
you're playing with the black pieces
it's a it will become a very open
position
and you are ahead in development so why
not just bust open the center if
possible
it shouldn't be possible but it seems it
is if double played it
so the critical variation uh jonas has
to consider here is
what happens uh if you don't uh if you
don't go after the d4 pawn but rather go
a capture sun b5 because black cannot
recapture the rook would be hanging on
a8
so the critical variation here is just
pawn captures on e4
bishop uh pawn captures on c6 we have e
captures on f3
queen captures and now e4 so this is the
critical variation to evaluate for duba
uh sorry for
for uh beer and uh it uh
it looks very uh interesting white is up
material
uh but uh can can he actually do
something about it after queen to e2
the engines do prefer white but dubois
had this prepared you you really have no
idea how to start
developing your pieces uh could be very
hard to play for white so white
completely ignored this continuation
and after doubles d5 he accepted the
dubose game so e captures and d5 was
played
attacking the knight here and now double
just goes knight to a5
attacking that bishop on b3 uh so he
offers yet another pawn on e5
uh jonas captures it we have knight
captures on e5 and now
knight characters on b3 and here there
are
some of the similar games but after c
captures on b3
this position has never been reached
again already as of move
11. so here duboff continues bishop to
b7
he puts pressure on the under the e5
pawn and here
uh white's absolute best move is knight
to c6 which is what jonas played
he attacks dubois's queen and the bishop
and also the bishop is already attacked
by the rook so you have to capture the
knight otherwise you're just going to
lose a piece
so bishop captures the captures on c6
and now duboff goes
bishop to c5 and this is the this is the
critical
moment in the game where bia needs to
decide how to continue here and the way
to continue here is to push the pawn all
the way to d4
now you are behind on development all of
your pieces are still on the back rank
and you need to start developing pieces
so here d4
uh giving away one of your one of your
pawns because you are up material
is the way to go but it's still it's
still really complicated for example
bishop captures
a captures on b5 and now knight to e4
going after this
f2 pawn uh the knight can never be
captured because bishop captures an f2
check
loses the loses the queen for white so
what you would have to do here
after this knight to e4 move is just go
bishop to e3
and now we'll have a set of trades
bishop captures f captures an e3 and now
after let's say a captures on b5 you can
just trade anything queen captures rook
captures
and now either knight a3 or or just
continue capturing captures captures and
knight a3
and you could get this position where
white is up upon
and the white should be a little bit
better but still it's very very unclear
so this is what white can go for however
here
beer decided to go d3 instead not push
the pawn all the way
he decided to keep his material
advantage but now
uh duval has one sneaky move up his
sleeve so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this move dupe of played
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations
as i know all of you got the move uh so
we're just going to show it
congratulations to everyone the move is
bishop capture sun f2 so congratulations
to everyone who found it
uh you if you don't capture uh the
bishop it's just bishop capture sunny
one and black has
enough to win the game so the bishop
must be captured which was played in the
game and now
queen to d4 with check and now again you
have so many options do you move the
king king g3 do you go king to f1 do you
go
king to king f3 uh what do you do with
the king well
uh it seems the most natural move it
seems is just to play bishop to e3
because it comes with an attack on the
queen
and you really don't care about uh queen
captures here because you're just gonna
block with the knight and the queen will
be guarding the rook so this is probably
what bi was hoping for
but instead dubo just went knight to g4
with check now attacked attacked
both the king and the bishop and now the
king needs to defend
the bishop uh because now the bishop is
attacked twice so king to f3 was played
now comes knight captures on e3 rook
captures in the rook eight to ea
threatening just queen captures on e3
and there really aren't all that many
good squares for this rook
there aren't any good squares for this
rook uh you could capture on e8 for
example rook captures rook captures but
it's still
uh how do you save this king at the e2
square is covered the f2 square is
covered and the king simply don't
doesn't have an escape route
so probably after queen to d2 uh you
would go rook to e6
and now again not not much for you to do
you can go check then go rook f2 check
uh there's simply nothing here or if
white goes g3
then it's the very tricky queen d5 check
king f2 and queen to h1
and there is uh there is no defense
against queen captures on h2
it's just uh a completely winning
position for duo
uh would be so after rook eight to e8 we
have
rook to e2 keeping the keeping the
tension here
but now comes queen to f6 checked by
dubo
uh now the king has to go up the board
these two squares are covered by the
queen and by the rook with king to g3
but now uh the position is completely
winning for black but
there is only one move that wins the
game here and it's not an easy one to
find so feel free to pause the video and
win the game for duboff while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
it's a
a very sneaky pawn move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
pawn to g5 so congratulations
congratulations to everyone who found
this
and also double congratulations if
you've found both this and the previous
one
and now the thread is just queen to f4
check followed by queen to h4
if white does something like rook
captures here it just queen for checking
h3
and queen to h4 will be checkmate so
that's out of the question so here
uh jonas tried rook to f2 with an attack
on the queen
this does prevent this uh queen to f4
move
but uh it uh it doesn't save you uh
it doesn't really save you uh we're just
going to show what happens if rook
rook to e4 is played it's kind of a move
that keeps
white in the game but it still loses
terribly after
uh rook captures because now again this
becomes the threat you don't have the
option of capturing the rook
and if queen f3 going uh for a queen
trade then just queen e5
check and there's nothing for for white
to do if the king goes here then rook to
h4
is again checkmate and if you go king of
two then rook to f4 just wins the queen
and the black is uh
so much up in material uh it would be
pointless to continue this so after g5
we have rook to f2 like we mentioned
uh prevents the queen to f4 but it
allows a different move for do both so a
lot of moves are winning here
uh but the move dooba plays is the
absolute quickest way to deliver
checkmate
and that is queen to d6 check this is a
start of a mating six so queen to d6
check
uh and now again uh what do you do uh if
you go king to f3 queen to f4 is made in
one
the rook cuts off the king away from the
e file so you have to go the other way
king the h3 was played
but now queen just finds a different way
around
uh queen to h6 check king to g uh three
or rather king to g4 was what was played
in the game but it doesn't really matter
and now queen to h for check and it was
in this position that uh jonas will be a
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here like we said if
king of three this is just checkmate so
that's out of the question
your only other option is to go up the
board but then it's just
queen to d4 you don't even have to
capture the rook queen to d4 with the
threat of rookie 5 is game over
if you block that for example rookie 2
then comes rook captures uh
queen captures and of course queen to f4
is again checkmate as the pawns cover
all of these squares in front of the
white king so really
a wild wild start of the of the team
championship
this was a game from round one and an
excellent game for duboff
uh duke actually finished the the entire
tournament without losing a single game
uh he won four games in drew three
and uh in the end russia won first place
uh so it was a
great result for russia and a great
result for for for dubai himself
uh so yeah that's uh the game really a
wild one it did not go past this point
so after queen to h4
uh it was just a nice resignation but uh
what i mean what a game so it all came
down to this uh
moment uh well there were there were a
few more nice moments it's hard to
pinpoint the critical one but if i
had to it would be this one where white
uh could have gone d4 but for some
reason went to d3
and and this was an over the board game
so it's not a mouse slip
so uh d4 d3 instead of d4 could have
gone
differently but you know you allow do
both such a
such a dubovious move uh you you you
will not have a great time
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys uh hope you guys enjoyed it as you
guys are
you know you guys keep requesting do
both games so i'm gonna show them as i
also enjoy them immensely
uh so we will see uh if we show more of
them or we maybe continue the morphe
saga we'll see how it goes but tomorrow
is the start of tata still so we're
probably gonna mostly cover that
uh but yeah uh so thanks again for for
watching uh i would like to thank james
butler
uh victor your guelescu uh alex holland
rendezvent
and yuri gladier for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day